little guys I'm Ryan right we're gonna
check out today from mind shop 10
scariest celebrity stalkers I want her
to watch this video when it was sent
because it was like I've always thought
if someone were to kill me mm-hmm it
should be like my most obsessive
subscriber you probably have a few
already I know and he's not gonna want
to share me so he's gonna kill me so he
can only have me or she who knows who it
is have you that's my celebrity death
right there yes I consider myself a
celebrity let's watch this people
number 10 God saved the undies to start
off this list let's begin with one of
the first celebrity stalkers I could
find Edward Jones when the 19th century
he was known as the buckingham palace
intruder why Jones fell in love with
Queen Victoria via painting he just had
to get closer to her he was caught in
1838 going through Queen Victoria's
dressing room with her underwear stuffed
down his pants holding a letter to the
Queen gangster he was not convicted of a
crime the man sure had tenacity even
after being caught he continued to break
into the palace up to the point where
the royal family had enough of them and
sent him to the Navy where he was to
never return to bother the Queen again
he still has the underwear nice good job
number nine Olympic level insanity in
2009 Shaun Johnson discovered the
dangers of being a young attractive girl
in Hollywood yes her name is Shaun try
not to get confused the Olympic gold
medal athlete was contestant on Dancing
with the Stars as a result of her fame
Florida and Robert Orion became
absolutely obsessed with her
he eventually traveled from Florida all
the way to the set of Dancing with the
Stars in California and dragged a
break-in to the set where he was
fortunately arrested the full extent of
his bizarre behavior became clear in the
trial on the way to California he was
stopped in Alabama
by an officer in the dashcam footage
they talked for 30 minutes about how he
was going to convince her to marry em
and that he had always been
telepathically communicating with her
it's kind of screaming as far as nice to
suggest that Johnson spoke to him during
the Beijing Olympics when they arrested
him they found two guns duct tape a
wooden Club and poetry among other small
gifts you're sure that's not how you
convince someone to marry you at least
not the right way poetry's weird
nobody Bieber fever it's no extreme haha
uber has a ton of fans but 45 year old
male Dana Martin did not fit the
description for the typical groupie in
prison he became so obsessed with Bieber
that he fashioned his own tattoo gun to
get a tattoo of Justin on his left leg
this rapist murderer who is sentenced to
life in prison then became angry for two
reasons
for one Bieber never responded and
second Bieber changed from his original
image because of that Martin conspired
with two other felons to kidnap Castries
and murder the pop idol oh my god art
and friends in a twist of fate thanks
took a turn for the worse when the two
contract killers turned onto the wrong
road and ended up at the Canadian border
instead of Vermont when stalked by the
police they discovered the plan the
tools the weapons and even a hand-drawn
picture of Justin Martin remains in jail
were in his last interview he said he
would still have sex with Justin yeah
they would not look good together
number seven letters to Leatherman
schizophrenia has never been a friend to
anyone for David Letterman he learned
this firsthand for over ten years a
Margaret Mary Rae believed him to be her
husband the erratic behavior that ensued
became a source of jokes made on a show
she was arrested eight times for
breaking into his home often showing up
with her child claiming that he was
Letterman's son Mary would also send him
letters and the occasional gift once she
even stole his car Letterman joked the
rapid changes address after a couple of
us she was sent to his psych ward where
she later changed her attention to a
retired astronaut she ended her spree of
stalking by committing suicide by
kneeling
from oncoming train in 1998 Oh No
number six a moment like this Sandra Mae
McIntyre was obsessed with Paula Abdul
she may have been a number one fan
Sandra changed her name legally to Paula
good speed and by 16 she dressed and
sounded exactly like Paula Abdul
although this look she wasn't entirely
grasping her image watch her audition on
American Idol when she finally got to me
a dull on the side of American Idol she
was very quickly rejected by the judges
frustrated with her situation Goodspeed
continued to stalk Abdul until the day
she overdosed in a car parked in front
of a Bill's home the police found inside
the car license plate of a BL LV and a
photo of the star she even sent flowers
just before her death at least she
finally got to meet her idol some people
wait a lifetime as funny as she was the
American Idol number 5 you have mail in
1999
Dante Michael so you sent mail to
Gwyneth Paltrow up to 10 packages per
day the contents oh my god flowers
letters candy pizza and most importantly
porn labelled with his and her name on
it every man show that the poulterer's
parents house even after the FBI warned
him to stop once he even sent her a
vibrator saying because I love you you
know and he claimed that he would put a
curse upon her parents if she stood up
to him Paltrow testified that she felt
threatened by him and that he sent her
sexually threatening messages when being
charged so you replied if a man he is a
woman unconditional love
she is blessed a little creepy but in
his letters he also claimed that he
would take God's scalpel and cut the sin
out of Paltrow whatever he means by that
it doesn't sound too good I don't know I
like the gun number 4 in the doghouse
actress Catherine zeta-jones is married
to actor Michael Douglas a crazy stalker
dawn at night is in love with Michael
Douglas - the solution stalking and
threats oh of course
Knight became very protective of Douglas
when she started reading magazines that
claim that zeta-jones was cheating on
him to counter
snipe again til zeta-jones says she was
cheating with Douglas already although
no one believes the story furthermore
night started to threaten her directly
saying quote we are going to slice her
up like meat on a bone and feed her to
the dogs in the trial that sent her to
jail Knight could be seen staring
silently as Etta Jones as she read your
actions will be with me for the rest of
my life how I will be constantly
observing and looking over my shoulder
she is already out of prison now that's
a real problem number three
mind control murder the pharmaceutical
companies must be going nuts because the
next stalker sure needed them Diane
Annapolis fervently believed that Steven
Spielberg and his wife were part of a
satanic called the practice child abuse
and that could catch other Souls
at the same time she would stalk both
Spielberg and Keira a different events
and movie premiere screaming everyone
murders in one claim she believed that
Hewitt practice - mind control by a
microchip and was trying to kill
Annapolis she's been prescribed
medication for a delusional behavior wow
that couldn't come sooner she has any of
the meds
number two John Hinckley jr. John
Hinckley jr. is famous in the USA for
being obsessed with Jodie Foster after
watching the movie taxi driver in 1980
he purposefully enrolled and followed
her to Yale University where he would
leave her notes and poems Wow
stick with the general of stalker
motives he would also repeatedly phone
her to no avail
since she didn't respond he dreamt of
hijacking an airplane or committing
suicide in front of her so that she
would finally notice him his last effort
plan involved assassinating the
president he sent one final letter
reading the reason I'm going ahead with
this attempt now is because I cannot
wait to impress you any longer Hinckley
later drove to Washington DC where he
shot six times at Ronald Reagan where
luckily no one died he was found not
guilty due to reason of insanity Jesus
yes I could understand that
number one happiness is a warm gun
arguably one of the most famous stalkers
in our recent history is Mark David
Chapman Chapman became intoxicated with
the idea of ending John Lennon in
October 1980 Chapman flew to New York to
finally conduct his plan it is reported
that he offered cocaine to the taxi
driver and ranted on to singer James
Taylor in the subway about how he was
going to get Lennon while sweating
profusely well sounds like a typical
cokehead to me as Lennon returned to his
hotel
Chapman shot Lennon five times and
instead of running stood there with this
signed copy of The Catcher in the Rye
reading in court he chose not to plead
insanity and rather pled to
second-degree murder he later said in an
interview that he killed Lennon just
because he was famous he probably could
have used Chapman when Hitler was around
then instead of killing a musical genius
he would be getting rid of a fascist
dictator weirdly ends on a positive note
like man if only we had this serial
killer is not circular phone let me have
this murder to kill Hitler like it makes
me think that we should take all
murderers train them to be fighters for
the US mm-hmm
send those guys overseas you know they
fight that's what I got from this video
how do you feel chelina I know you love
[ __ ] like this I do like the number 10
story of the Queen where he the guys
stole her underwear you know like if I
was to actually go after celebrity let's
say I don't know she looks like I'm
thinking of the perfect celebrity that I
would go after Ryan Gosling if I went
after Ryan Gosling yeah I'd steal his
underwear is used underwear Veronica I
would steal Ryan Gosling's used
underwear we'd hang it up on the wall
behind for everyone to smell I want to
leave the guys Justin Bieber tattoos
oh yeah the date with a Justin Bieber
obsession yeah you know like that's
crazy Bieber fever this could be a movie
right
they just called Bieber fever and it's
about the guy who wanted to kill Justin
Bieber because he changed it makes me
scared to grow and change that's why I
resort to dick and [ __ ] jokes Justin
Bieber must have so many stalkers like
like oh yeah freakin creepy little girl
star wars oh yes even scarier than that
guy one of those little girls is gonna
get to him and actually complete the
mission of castrating Justin Bieber now
if I had Justin Bieber's balls that
would go next to Ryan Gosling's
underwear Bieber's balls that's what I
would call yeah
Bieber's balls huh baby I'm gonna
castrate Justin Bieber
I'm not Ricky hasn't been castrated
right we'll never know if I were to have
a stalker I'd want one like the Paula
Abdul one where this person wants to
like dress and become like me like some
dude who's like black shows up with like
an afro wears the same clothes he's like
what are you gonna say no you had
something in mind I know I'd be pretty
flattered actually what just one yeah so
are these sound flattering the one that
was truly [ __ ] up was was the one we
all know about the John Lennon one yeah
yeah like there's no jokes to be made
there but all these other ones like I
don't feel like the stalker is never one
the one with Michael Douglas and
Catherine zeta-jones yeah yeah I know
their stalker 108 is out of prison - and
which is weird because I know Michael
Douglas is obsessed with black chicks
how do you do that it's a fetish he
always brings black chicks into the room
he's talked about this openly in many
interviews on talk shows when you guys
hang out no one talked to us yeah before
you resort to sarcasm that is the truth
I know what it's like to obsess over
someone or obsess over like a girl or
something like we're like you just for
some reason some of them might not be
into you but you keep thinking about
them I kind of feel like this sort of
goes
that's that but in a much more
heightened degree yeah it'd be like an
addiction where like you do sort of
think about them it goes back to they're
just obsessed with someone who's
emotionally unavailable for them yeah
yep who is your biggest obsession in
your entire life is there anyone like as
a child that you were just like Neve
Campbell when I was really young
no Campbell really yeah she was in
scream and I was I felt so sorry for her
well this [ __ ] she had to go through and
I'm moving I don't know anything about
Justin Timberlake with his really curly
afro I had like my entire wall covered
no one asked you about Jackie thunder
okay anyway guys thanks for tuning in to
the channel if you're new to it you can
subscribe today and become a reject inna
yeah
that's Spanish for reject you can check
out color by energy from show Leanna
Myers she has an event that's hosted
monthly it's so [ __ ] cool he gets a
collection of different artists there
and they tend to be pretty good let's
say 9 out of 10 we're all yeah but
they're still supportive even if they're
[ __ ]